("Melodramatic Confession")
- Oh.
(crew laughs)
I was like, where's the
rest of the song at?
(runway music)
(playful brass music)
- Today, we are vogueing
to random stock music,
so let's see how this goes.
(giggles)
("Jingle Bell Hop")
(laughs)
("No Dough")
♪ You need the money for the meter ♪
♪ Money for the toll ♪
♪ Don't turn on the heater ♪
♪ Daddy is on the dough
♪ ♪ They tell me that ♪
♪ The devil plays good
money for your soul ♪
♪ We don't got no dough ♪
♪ Tell me there's a dollar
in the pocket of your jeans ♪
♪ Need money for the baby,
the bacon and the beans ♪
♪ I'd buy you a dozen roses ♪
♪ But I just don't have the means ♪
♪ Don't got no dough ♪
- This is fun.
Very random, very fun, though.
("Unusual Suspects")
(laughs)
(crew laughs)
- I feel (laughs).
("Superfly")
- All right, I'm ready for the next one.
("Twin Planets")
(laughing)
- [Angelica] Woo, those were interesting.
Those were all great.
You gotta be able to move to anything.
(lighthearted music)